hallo mein Name ist Luca und meine Damen
und Herren vor einigen Tagen habe ich
dieses Video hier auf meinem Youtube
Kanal hochgeladen in dem ich auf die
deutsche Version des Netflix Formats
reagiert habe bei Twitter zu Ende geht
es darum dass verschiedene Models
Influenza Leute aus der ganzen Welt auf
eine Insel gelockt werden um dort
angeblich bei einer dating Show
teilzunehmen bei der man was miteinander
hatte rumliegt etc pp dann allerdings
von Netflix aufgelöst wird dass wir
tourne sind und gar nichts miteinander
haben dürfen sonst verlieren sie eine
Menge Geld habe ich einige Sachen
kritischen hinterfragt wodurch sich
jetzt vor einigen Tagen dieses Video
hier aufgetan hat Luca lügt was bei
Twitter eine wirklich passiert und die
Userin dieses Video hier hochgeladen hat
heißt Anna und hat wohl bei Twitter
Germany mitgemacht von daher bin ich mal
gespannt was sie mir hier vorwirft und
sagt willkommen zu einem neuen Video
von Laser Luca die Reaktion auf toilet
Germany gesehen habe wusste ich ich muss
meinen Teil dazu sagen warum
Germany als Teilnehmer ihr wollt mir
anschauen was wirklich hinter den
Kulissen passiert ihr habt Verträge hier
ich habe
und ich muss sagen
nicht so richtig drauf deshalb würde ich
sagen schauen wir uns alles an ich habe
erst vier Minuten gesehen heißt es wird
interessant und ich würde sagen wir
fangen an let's go
ich habe einige Sachen nicht so wirklich
drauf
ich weiß nicht mehr wer sie ist too hot
to handle ist so Sticker das bekannte
lol jetzt
reagiere ich wie sie auf mich reden
wusste gar nicht auch sie kritisiert
mich dafür dass ich angeblich gar nichts
kann was ist denn das für ein
cam-ausschnitt da oben
ist das meine Cam also ich schieb dir
mal so ein bisschen runter jetzt mal
gerade meine Camp verdeckt halt
logischerweise meine Cam deswegen die
Passagen wo ich jetzt hier rede nämlich
jetzt mein Video schon gesehen sonst
wird das ja alles voll den Rahmen
sprengen
ich lese gerade mal die Kommentare durch
angeblich wird die mich noch krank
Fronten in diesem Video hier also die
ganze Kommentare hier sind auf meiner
Seite und sagen warte mal ich zeige euch
ein paar hier gibt Stress mit Luca Fans
ich finde auch dass Luca seine Meinung
dazu haben kann und Anna ihn nicht so
haten soll ich glaube nicht dass Luca
dich in irgendeiner Weise Fronten wollte
ich glaube ihr habt euch missverstanden
ich denke Luca wollte dich auf gar
keiner Weise Fronten oder dissen
bestimmt gab es nur ein paar
Missverständnisse oder verschiedene
Meinungen die falsch verstanden wurden
er hat einfach nur gesagt wie er es
erlebt hat das hat jetzt gar nichts mit
anderen Mädchen Frauen zu tun es gibt
auch emotional und einfühlsame Frauen er
will niemanden Fronten so ist Luca nicht
ich finde dich echt sympathisch und
lieber deine Videos aber for real Luca
so zu Fronten muss ja echt nicht sein
vieles davon dient nur zu kommen die und
ist nicht böse gemeint an sich hat er es
ja auch wirklich spaßig rübergebracht
manchmal sollte man nicht alles so ernst
nehmen ich hoffe er gibt ihr kein
bisschen Aufmerksamkeit das ist doch
genau das was sie mit dem Video
bezwecken wollte einer der meint das
alles nicht böse und ich glaube würdet
ihr euch so mal treffen würdet ihr euch
gut verstehen und warum bist du schon
von Anfang an so aggressiv gegenüber
Luca man muss sich nicht immer
angegriffen fühlen Hauptsache auf Lukas
Nacken Klicks machen absolut
unsympathisch Lukas kein Typ der
irgendwelche Leute frontet an manchen
Stellen vielleicht schlecht ausgedrückt
aber es ist ja auch zum Teil Comedy was
er macht da ist der Titel und thumbnail
deines Videos echt unnötig das hätte man
besser machen können okay also ich bin
gespannt also sorry dass er soll jetzt
nicht dumm klingt nicht dass sie sich
auch hier angegriffen fühlt ich ich weiß
nicht wer sie ist ich habe glaube ich
auf sie auch gar nicht so richtig genau
in dem Video reagiert ich hatte mich
daher auf die anderen Teilnehmer so ein
bisschen beschränkt die sie halt total
zum Affen gemacht haben in ihren
Interviews damit komischen Aussagen ja
ich werde jetzt noch mal sagen ich sag
das ihnen jeder reaction nichts von dem
was ich sage ist irgendwie böse gemeint
es geht doch nicht gegen irgendwelche
Person dahinter ich kenne die alle nicht
ähm die da irgendwie dran teilgenommen
haben es ging mir ein lediglich um
einige stumpf dumme Aussagen ja
irgendwie getroffen wurden und dass ich
nicht so ganz nachvollziehen konnte wie
man sich ähm so verträglich nicht durch
weil es muss halt vertraglich juristisch
festgehalten sein dass
wir schauen uns das mal sorry dass der
ganz kurz interveniere
keiner der TeilnehmerInnen kennt
wahrscheinlich dieses Wort also
[Musik]
ja herzlichen Glückwunsch das war Ironie
tatsächlich es muss in einem Vertrag
genauestens drinstehen auf was du dich
dort einlässt ich habe den Vertrag extra
rausgesucht um mir das noch mal
durchzulesen weil ich verstehe das
Argumente schreiben mir auch ganz viele
die glauben nicht dass wir das wirklich
nicht wussten also vorab mal es war
super Smite gemacht Vertrag ist hier wir
lesen den jetzt mal ich darf den euch
natürlich eine zeigen und Elise auch nur
den relevanten Teil und zwar hat sich
die Produktion damit abgesichert dass
sie geschrieben haben die Produktion mit
dem Arbeitstitel tropical Desire der
heißeste tripternes Lebens nachfolgen
Produktion die Produktion ist einen
Ausland gedrehte Reality Show blablabla
mehr Info ist nicht wirklich relevant
aber dieser Begriff arbeitsstitel ne die
hatte in meinem Studium auch sechs
Semester lang recht und mit Arbeitstitel
kann man schon viel machen weil ein
Arbeitstitel ist nicht der finale Titel
ja danke schön das weiß ich auch
ich ich also falls Sie das nicht so ganz
verstanden hat ich hatte keinen Vertrag
vorliegen und in einem Vertrag dafür
macht man einen Vertrag muss eins zu
eins drin stehen was Phase ist wenn die
das so verschleiert dargestellt haben
hätte ich es erst gar nicht
unterschrieben aber das ist ja jedem
selbst überlassen das war auch nur ein
nur wirklich wieder übertrieben gemeint
dass ich gesagt habe ich könnte doch
Netflix auf Millionen verteilen das wird
natürlich kein Teilnehmer machen weil
die dadurch natürlich profitieren
dadurch bekommen sie ihre Reichweite sie
bekommen jetzt hier gerade auch
Reichweite ich meine Video was ja
anscheinend auch so ein bisschen mit
Zwecken will aber darauf wollte ich nur
hinaus trotzdem rechtskräftig also von
dem er ist dieses
außer Kraft es ist gar nichts außer
Kraft weil du hast einen Satz vom
Vertrag vorgelesen der wahrscheinlich
fünf bis zehn Seiten lang ist
also sie hat nur kurz erklärt dass das
ein Arbeitstitel war ja da geht's ja
trotzdem nicht um den Gegenstand des
Vertrags aber ist egal
warum tut sie denn so als hätte sie das
Video noch nicht gesehen
oh mein Gott was kommt jetzt aber sie
muss das Video ja schon gesehen haben
weil sie ja extra vorher auch schon den
Vertrag rausgesucht hat weil sie ja
schon wusste dass ich jetzt mit dem
Vertrag ansprechen das heißt ja dass das
dass ihre Reaktion jetzt gerade nur
gespielt ist oder sehe ich das also
bitte nicht angefühlt
einfach von irgendwo aufgeschnappt dass
diese eine tiktokerin die mit ihrer Oma
Videos macht bei turt200 Germany ist und
dachte die erste Blondine die rein läuft
ist es hallo Luca darf ich mir
vorstellen ich bin die richtige Blondine
die Videos mit ihren mit ihrer Omi macht
üben ich kenne dich nicht Anna also ist
auch wieder nicht böse gemeint aber ich
weiß nicht wer sie ist ich kannte sie
nicht vorher ich habe auch wenn ich sie
jetzt so getroffen hätte auf der Straße
hätte ich auch nicht gewusst dass sie
dorthin mitmachen aber wie gesagt ich
glaube ich habe auf jeden Fall gar nicht
so richtig reagiert und um das auch mal
ganz kurz zu sagen ich habe auch nicht
die erste Blondine da irgendwie
verwechselt mit dir lieber Anna sondern
ich meine tatsächlich die Emily und das
stimmte auch eins zu eins was ich gesagt
habe ich blende euch hier mal die Videos
ein auf die ich mich bezogen habe du
hast gesagt dass ich nur viel Lust date
was steht denn auf meinem Pulli drauf
die Flocken hätte wie ein Herz und
manche an wie bei dir ich habe meinen
zukünftigen Mann auch
Videos die ich euch gerade eingeblendet
t habe waren die Videos die ich in
meiner Reaktion meinte die Videos habe
ich von der Emily von der Teilnehmerin
namens auf tiktok ins Kopf heißt sie
glaube ich gesehen die Videos haben
Millionen Aufrufe die Waren auf meiner
for you Page und deswegen meinte ich als
gesehen habe in meiner ersten reaction
auf Tour zu Ende das äh ich sie glaube
ich von tiktok kennen von Videos die sie
mit ihrer Oma gemacht hat also weiß
nicht was sie jetzt gerade irgendwie
bezwecken will aber wir schauen mal
weiter
sind wir doch ganz AMS ab aber jetzt
schauen wir mal weiter ob er vielleicht
noch checkt dass Emily nicht ich ist
da es ist nicht böse gemeint aber es
geht nicht nur um dich Anna ich meinte
Emily ich hatte Recht ich habe euch
gerade die Videos eingeblendet also
warum frontet sie denn so hey ich habe
nicht bei ihren Namen glaube ich in
meinem Video in dem Moment das ist genau
so sinnbefreit wie wenn bei GNTM dann
unten steht kommt aus Österreich nein
Bro das ist Germany's next Topmodel
nicht okay soll das jetzt Front gegen
Österreicher sagen hey wie kann man
sorry fühl Dich bitte nicht angegriffen
ich wollte auch hiermit nicht bezwecken
dass du dich als Österreicher in deiner
Kultur in deinem Patriotismus
angegriffen fühlst um Gottes Willen ich
liebe Österreich ob das immer schon
gesagt ich bin Österreich ist ein super
schönes Land ich fahre jeden Winter nach
Österreich mit meiner Family für zwei
Wochen Skifahren also ich habe absolut
nichts
warum warum
ich gerade rechtfertigen muss ich habe
einfach nur gesagt das heißt Germany
Germany's next Topmodel Tour Channel
Germany es gibt einfach keinen Sinn dass
wenn du eine Serie
mit Deutschland oder Germany halt
betitelt das dann Leute mit dabei sind
die nicht aus Deutschland kommen darum
geht es einfach nur
aus Österreich so kann danke
[Musik]
absolut langweilig wird
ach komm so schlimm ist es nicht doch es
ist so schlimm
aber es ist alles humorvoll gemeint also
bitte fühl Dich auch nicht angegriffen
natürlich danke ich habe mich gerade
schon gefragt
es ist auch ein Joke gewesen
wahrscheinlich geht zumindest aus der
Bibel oder 2020 hat für ihn irgendeine
Bedeutung um Gottes Willen also wenn man
solche Witze halt nicht versteht dann
ist man glaube ich bei mir auf dem Kanal
generell an der falschen Adresse ich
meine überhaupt nichts böse ich möchte
niemanden Freund ich will mit niemand
Stress erkennen nicht es ist einfach
alles wird einfach ein dummer Typ der
gerne jokes macht also bitte fühlt euch
nicht angegriffen mal schauen dass ich
ich sag's jetzt noch mal und es ist
wieder nicht böse gemeint aber ich kenne
dich nicht ich weiß dass sie auf Youtube
jetzt 250.000 Abonnenten hat aber ich
ich kenne die anderen nicht das ist auch
nicht böse gemeint es gibt auch
irgendwelche Kranken Stars
wahrscheinlich auf der Welt die
Millionen von Followern haben auf
Instagram die kenne ich auch nicht ich
kenne sie nicht ich kannte nur diese
Emily von tiktok von den Videos die ich
euch bereits eingeblendet habe und da
hatte ich auch recht und genau das
meinte ich
Punkte Emily heißt ja glaube ich diese
Emily will auf jeden Fall mein character
sein Okay Luca was du nicht verstehst
ähm bevor du wieder was sagst ich
verwechsel nicht dich mit Emily bitte
nicht angegriffen ist natürlich schon
aber das ist ja eine Sendung die wird
zusammengeschnitten
[Musik]
noch krass erzähl mir mehr ich wusste
nicht dass das geschnitten wird
schon auch ein bisschen besser und die
wird behaupten in der
Situation
vielleicht auch mit den anderen Frauen
obwohl ich hoffe dass es nicht so bei
uns der Fall war aber irgendwo ist man
halt und klarerweise richtet man sich
dann oft und ist generell nervös und
nicht unbedingt weil sie sich jetzt
denkt oh mein Gott
[Musik]
sage ich auch gar nichts gegen das war
ja auch null böse gemeint also bitte
falls die Emily das eventuell aussehen
sollte ich hoffe du verstehst das im
Vergleich zu einer so ein bisschen dass
das halt einfach eine Feststellung war
also ich habe gesagt man merkt direkt
siemencharakter sie redet direkt sie
kommt aus sich raus sie faszinieren
nichts Werten gemeint
also anscheinend ihr checkt das ja so da
habt ihr auch bei ihr beim Video hier
kommentiert aber ähm ich will das zum 20
Mal so noch mal ganz kurz darstellen
kein Kommentar von mir das böse gemeint
und wenn irgendwas vielleicht so
rüberkommen könnte dann tut's mir leid
aber versteht bitte einfach das halt
mein Humor ist kein Korb akzeptieren
kann ist kein Mann vielleicht gesagt
wenn man keine kriegt
[Musik]
ich glaube wir sind jetzt
verstehen uns mittlerweile
[Musik]
miteinander klarkommen erst lacht sie
über mein Video lacht darüber dass ich
mir den Kopf stoße und dann plötzlich
wieder an ich bin ja sauer auf denen aus
irgendeinem unbekannten Grund niemanden
juckt deine Uhr Luca weißt du was juckt
diese komische Freundin da von dir im
Hintergrund die ganze Zeit Karotten ist
sie hat doch gar keinen Mehrwert fürs
Video an dieser Stelle auch bitte nicht
angegriffen fühlen zwar auch Mike singer
und samichlierer genauso aus sind Fabian
Acker aus Wien
[Musik]
ergibt keinen Sinn
weil als ich reinkam steht unter meinem
Namen Innsbruck und ich wette du
wusstest nicht dass Innsbruck in
Österreich ist
[Musik]
Innsbruck Wien Hauptsache Spanien bitte
nicht angegriffen ein Mädchen war mit
der ich was hatte sie wirklich
emotional gesehen nicht so am Start war
weil und da habe ich danke für diese
Intervention das Show ähm
habe ich nie gesagt
aber ähm
erstmal ganz kurz anders ergibt keinen
Sinn dass du jemanden Front ist und dann
noch Front sagst aber darauf will ich
mich gar nicht beziehen sondern auf
meine Aussage davon gerade das ist
nämlich einfach die Erfahrung die ich
gemacht habe und ich habe hier nicht
alle Frauen und Mädels auf der Welt so
wie sie das anscheinend die
interpretiert hat gejagt und gefrontet
und keine Ahnung was gemacht also ich
hoffe das kam im Video auch nicht falsch
rüber weil ich habe ja ehrlich gesagt
einfach ist ja logisch wenn ich sage ich
habe die Erfahrung gemacht oder wenn ich
was ein Mädels hatte war es halt so dass
ich jetzt nur auf mich beziehe also bei
mir war es halt immer so dass wenn ich
mit dem Mädchen was hatte die hübsche
die Person war desto weniger Charakter
stärker hatte diese Person so gefühlt
ich habe auch diesen Kommentar unter
meiner reaction gelesen der auch sehr
sehr gut war hatte ich auch tatsächlich
vor einem Tagen schon direkt runter
kommentiert das ist ein guter Punkt ist
auf jeden Fall da hat nämlich ein
Mädchen geschrieben habt ihr ich habe es
euch gerade eingelegt ein Mädchen
geschrieben dass sie auch von vielen
Freunde immer gesagt bekommen dass sie
eigentlich auch recht hübsch ist aber
sie sieht sich selber auch als Person
die natürlichen Charakter hat natürlich
sie ist lustig hat humorvolle Art und so
ist ein sympathischer Mensch ihre
Ansicht nach aber das sieht so die
Erfahrung gemacht hat das Typen sie oft
nur aus äußerliche reduzieren und gar
nicht mal was Ernstes suchen und sie
dadurch ihren Charakter gar nicht
richtig zeigen kann das ist dann
natürlich sehr schade und darauf ich
wollte das wie gesagt auf gar nichts
beziehen ich habe einfach nur von meinen
Erfahrungen gesprochen das ist genauso
extrem dummes beispielsweise aber das
genauso wenig sage jede Frau mit der ich
bisher was hatte hatte übelsten Axel
Geruch damit möchte ich nicht alle
Mädels auf der Welt klatschen ich will
einfach nur sagen dass ich diese
Erfahrung gemacht habe also sorry noch
mal falls es irgendwie falsch ankam ihr
kennt mich ich möchte jemanden fremden
ich akzeptiere alle Menschen wie sie
sind
ziemlich ein bisschen schade dass man
mir hier im ganzen Video irgendwie so
gefühlt die Worte im Mund umdreht ich
glaube wir sind uns bei einer Sache
einig ich bin pansexuell heißt ich kann
über Frauen und Männer hier urteilen und
alles dazwischen und es ist meiner
Meinung nach wirklich immer so
attraktive Männer und natürlich auch
Frauen die hatten alle an schwachen
Charakter mit denen ich zumindest zu tun
hatte und das ist doch eins zu eins das
was ich gesagt habe
das ist doch zu 100% 1:1 komplett
identisch mit meiner Aussage dich
getroffen habe für die sie mich vorhin
noch gefreut hat wo sie wohin noch meint
er das liegt wahrscheinlich daran weil
du dir solche Mädels aussuchen und jetzt
sagt sie eins dasselbe
das sind jetzt subjektive Erfahrungen
die wir einfach gemacht haben die
anscheinend die anderen gemacht hat und
die auch ich gemacht habe und genau das
habe ich auch in meinem Video gesagt ich
habe die Ansicht und ich habe es so
erlebt dass wenn eine Frau mit der ich
etwas hatte je hübscher sie war desto
weniger Charakter hatte die Person das
ist so in so eine Richtung gegangen das
heißt nicht dass ich das auf alle Mädels
auf alle Frauen weltweit beziehe sorry
falls das so rüber kam dann tut es mir
leid falls ich da jemand angegriffen
gefühlt hat aber ich habe das nur auf
mich und meine Erfahrungen bezogen
natürlich gibt es auch Menschen egal
welche Sexualität egal was die mit zehn
von zehn vom äußerlichen sind aber auch
in zehn von zehn Charakter haben logisch
aber diese Erfahrung habe ich einfach
noch nicht gemacht
jetzt am Ende bin ich überrascht wir
sehen uns teilweise
weißt du davon halten soll
weiß nicht was ich davon halten soll
also vielleicht in aller erster Linie
mal das Ändern wo ganz fett Lügner steht
dann eventuell auch den Titel wo steht
Luca lügt
weil sie jetzt nicht so ganz wo ich in
dem Video gelogen habe aber okay
allerdings würde ich an der Stelle jetzt
meine reaction auf ihre reaction auf
meine reaction auf Tour to channel
Germany auch beenden ich habe dieses
Video hier ein zweimal zugeschickt
bekommen von Leuten die meinten ey Luca
stell das mal bitte klar sie hat
irgendwie eine komplett verdrehte
Ansicht und versteht dich irgendwie
nicht so ganz da haben wir auch schon in
den Kommentaren gesehen ich weiß nicht
ob das dann Missverständnis von ihr war
oder ob ich mich falsch ausgedrückt habe
in meinem Video mir ist es eigentlich
immer wichtig dass jeder versteht und
jeder der mich kennt er weiß es sowieso
dass viele Sachen humorvoll gemeint sind
ironisch gemeint sind und ähm weiß jetzt
nicht ganz so richtig was sie halt mit
dem Titel unter wahrscheinlich nichts
machen oder so ist ja auch in Ordnung
also funktioniert der ganze Bums ja auch
aber ich finde es komisch wenn wir
Wörter und umgedreht werden und Dich
dargestellt werde als würde ich
irgendwie Frauen hey ich werde angerufen
vor der Tür lassen Daumen hoch da wenn
es euch gefallen hat abonniert meinen
Kanal für mehr und klickt auf die Glocke
damit ihr das nicht verpasst wir sehen
uns Haut